vamos con el problema 22 22 en el
problema 22 simplemente nos piden
determinar el valor de un entero x
sabemos que x eres entero y queremos
saber cuál es en el enunciado 1 de
información nos dicen que x es un número
primo x es primo pero eso no nos sirve
para mucho verdad de hecho existe una
infinidad de primos entonces eso no nos
permite determinar x así solito y el
enunciado 2 dice que 31 es menor o igual
que x que es menor o igual que 37 por
supuesto este enunciado por sí mismo nos
sirve para determinar x porque este es
todo un rango de valores y juntando los
dos pues tampoco tampoco podemos
determinar x porque tanto 31 como 37 son
números primos si son números primos
entonces pues tenemos la ambigüedad de
no saber si x es 31 37 entonces ni
siquiera juntando los dos podemos
determinar el valor de x vale y aquí en
vez de menor o igual tuviéramos menor
estricto por ejemplo entonces x sería 37
o si éste fuera un menor estricto pues
aquí aquí sería 31 pero
no lo tenemos esta información no es
suficiente para determinar el valor de x
y por lo tanto la respuesta es y la
respuesta es muy bien vamos ahora al
problema 23 el problema 23 aquí nos
dicen que pq y r son tres puntos tres
puntos en el plano y nos preguntan si si
el segmento pq tiene la misma longitud
que el segmento p r si pq tiene la misma
longitud que pr b r ok y las opciones
que nos dan son las siguientes en el
inciso 1 en el enunciado 1 tenemos que
es el punto medio del segmento r vamos a
dibujarlo se vería más o menos algo así
voy a pintar por aquí el segmento el
segmento qr
r y nos dicen que p es el punto medio p
es el punto medio entonces esto de aquí
mide lo mismo que estoy acá es decir pr
es igual a pq y eso es justo lo que
necesitábamos para determinar si se daba
esta igualdad o no entonces esta
información de aquí es suficiente saber
que p es el punto medio del segmento q r
es suficiente para responder si p cub es
igual a pr vale ahora vamos a ver qué
dice que dice lin si son número dos a
ver si dice algo también interesante en
el inciso número dos nos dicen que q y r
caen en la misma circunferencia con
centro p eso suena muy bien a ver vamos
a tomar por ahí p por ahí está p y vamos
a tomar una circunferencia con centro en
p vale y sabemos que quiere caen sobre
esta circunstancia entonces por ahí en
algún lugar esta q y en algún otro lugar
está r bueno pues una circunferencia
justo es el conjunto de puntos que
equidistante de un cierto punto en una
distancia fija entonces pues por
supuesto que pr es igual a pq por que pr
r es igual al radio de la circunferencia
y pq también es igual al radio de la
circunferencia entonces pr es igual a pq
y con esta información con la del inciso
2 también podemos responder si esta
igualdad es cierta o no vale estar aquí
era una pregunta entonces la respuesta
sería de cualquiera de estos dos
enunciados nos permite responder si pq
es igual a pr va vamos al problema 24 lo
voy a poner en color azul problema 24 y
nos pregunta si x está entre 0.2 y 0.7
0.2 es menor que x
que es menor que 0.7 el enunciado 1 de
información nos dice que 560 x es menor
que 280 280 dividiendo entre 560 de
ambos lados esto es lo mismo a pedir que
x sea menor que 280 entre 560 y esto
cuánto es pues 28 entre 56 es un medio
los ceros se cancelan entonces esto es
igual a un medio entonces este enunciado
simplemente dice que x es x es menor que
un medio entonces eso pues nos nos ayuda
a verificar que es menor que 0.7 porque
un medio es 0.5 pero no nos dice nada
del otro extremo así que este por sí
mismo todavía no es suficiente y vamos a
ver qué dice el enunciado dos enunciados
el enunciado 2 dice que 700 x 700 ex le
gana a 280 le gana a 280 muy bien
entonces ahora dividimos entre 700 nos
queda que x le gana a 280 entre sí
de cientos y esto que es pues esto es lo
mismo que pues 28 entre 70 que es lo
mismo que 2.8 entre 7 es decir nos dice
que x le gana le gana a 0.4 sale
entonces aquí tenemos que x es menor que
0.5 aquí que es mayor que 0.4 la de
abajo por sí misma no es suficiente
ayuda a acotar x por abajo pero por
arriba quién sabe pero juntando las dos
ahora sí tenemos lo que queremos si x es
mayor que 0.4 entonces es mayor que 0.2
y si es menor que 0.5 es menor que 0.7
entonces sabiendo la información de las
dos si podemos concluir si podemos
concluir que x está en este intervalo y
la respuesta entonces sería c creo que
es nuestra primer set nuestra primer
sede de todo el examen se quiere decir
cada una de estas no es suficiente por
sí sola pero si juntamos las dos
entonces si es suficiente vale muy bien
ahora vamos al problema al problema 25
problemas 25 y el problema 25 dice que
son enteros y queremos determinar si
j&j es par
y sabemos que y j son enteros vale el
enunciado 1 de información nos dice que
y es menor que 10 pues en realidad esto
no nos ayuda para nada para saber la
paridad verdad entonces ésta no nos
sirve por sí misma y el inciso 2 nos
dice que y es igual a jota y es igual a
jota
esto está mucho mejor sí y es igual a
jota entonces y más jota es lo mismo que
y más y que es igual a dos veces si o
también podemos escribir esto
sustituyendo jota por y por jota y nos
quedaría que jota más j
o sea y más jota jota jota que es dos j
y en cualquier caso nos queda un número
par verdad porque es dos veces un entero
entonces está ya casi permite responder
la pregunta y por lo tanto la respuesta
es ve muy bien vamos ahora el problema
vamos acá abajo el problema 26 dice lo
siguiente problema 26 problema 26 tiene
más cada tiene más acá es igual a m cuál
es el valor de cada queremos determinar
el valor de cada bueno pues vamos a
despejar acá para tener un poco más con
que trabajar entonces pues restando n de
ambos lados nos queda que acá es igual a
m
n y ahora sí vamos a ver qué qué
información posible nos dan en el inciso
1 tenemos que n es igual a 10 en es
igual a 10
que por supuesto eso por sí mismo no nos
dice nada de acá porque me podría hacer
cualquier otra cosa verdad y de alguna
forma el inciso 2 nos da m pues ya vamos
a poder juntar las dos pero bueno ésta
por sí misma no funciona le voy a poner
una chiquita y ahora vamos a ver qué
dice el inciso 2 el inciso 2 dice dice
que m 10m más 10 es igual a n a ver
vamos a reflexionar tantito seguro las
dos juntas y funciona en verdad sabiendo
n podemos pues encontrar m y sabiendo m
podemos encontrar acá pero a lo mejor
está solita es suficiente a ver lo que
necesitamos es emmm entonces vamos a
restar n de ambos lados m n más 1010 es
igual a 0 y ahora restando 10 de ambos
lados tenemos que m
n es igual a menos 10 ok entonces ya
tenemos m
n y eso justo era acá sale entonces tan
sólo teniendo la información de dos
podemos determinar el valor de k y por
lo tanto la respuesta es b el inciso 12
es suficiente para determinar el valor
todavía tenemos tiempo si nos quedan
como 3 minutos o quizás un poquito más
para otro problema entonces vamos a
hacer el problema 27 problema 27 y aquí
nos ponen de dibujo un triángulo déjame
ponerlo por acá a lo mejor no queda tan
bonito como en el examen pero pero bueno
más o menos se va a ver la idea entonces
tenemos ese triángulo dice que aquí mide
x grados que acá mide z grados
centãgrados y acá nos pide acá nos dice
que mide 10 grados y la pregunta es
determinar si es equilátero es el latero
equilátero bueno pues qué posibilidades
de información tenemos o cuáles son las
opciones que nos dan en el inciso 1 nos
dicen que x es igual allí y x es igual
ay bueno pues eso todavía no es
suficiente para determinar que este
triángulo sea equilátero verdad
simplemente saber que este ángulo este
ángulo es igual a este ángulo de acá
solo nos permite concluir que este lado
es igual a este lado de acá déjame girar
el triángulo para que se parezca a algo
que hemos
antes las otras de los otros vídeos de
geometría entonces si tenemos que este
es x este eje y este z si x es igual a
ye este mide lo mismo que éste entonces
simplemente tenemos que el triángulo es
isósceles de hecho puedes intentar jugar
para verificarlo por tu cuenta
intenta hacer un triángulo con dos
ángulos iguales pero los lados
correspondientes distintos y no se va a
poder porque pues se prueba que no se
puede vale pero bueno entonces x igual
hay es simplemente nos dice que estos
dos lados son iguales pero eso todavía
no nos permite concluir que el triángulo
sea equilátero o determinar si lo es o
no lo es cierto sólo tenemos dos lados
iguales y para un triángulo equilátero
necesitamos que los tres ángulos los
tres ángulos sean iguales o bien los
tres lados sean iguales y en este caso
los tres ángulos van a ser iguales a 60
grados pero bueno el chiste es que ésta
por sí misma no nos permite concluir que
el triángulo sea equilátero vamos a ver
qué dice el 2 y el inciso de información
número 2 nos dice que z
z es igual a 60 bueno pues el inciso 2
por sí mismo tampoco nos permite
determinar que el triángulo equilátero
hay muchos triángulos que tienen un
ángulo de 60 porque esto básicamente nos
está diciendo que un ángulo es de 60
pero que no son equiláteros por ejemplo
el famosísimo triángulo de 30 60 90 y
así este ángulo es de 60 grados y este
es de 30 grados entonces este es de 90
para que sume en 180 y este de aquí
claramente no es equilátero entonces
esta información por sí misma no nos
permite determinar si el triángulo
equilátero no pero qué sucede si las
combinamos si las combinamos seguro pasa
algo interesante si combinamos está con
esta entonces pues ahora qué sucede
tenemos que que este ángulo es de 60
entonces pues yo creo que ahora si todos
son de 60 vamos a ver si lo podemos
probar sabemos que la suma de los tres
ángulos del triángulo x más ye maceta es
igual a 180 es igual a 180 grados
entonces x + ye más detalles 180 grados
vale pero si sabemos la información de 2
sabemos que z es 60 así
restando z de ambos lados o sea 60 de
ambos lados tenemos que x + es igual a
120 grados pero si además sabemos que x
es igual hay entonces x debe ser igual a
ye y de y esto debe ser igual a 60
grados vale para que sumados nos den 120
y además sean iguales entonces
combinando esta información con esta
información los tres ángulos son de 60
grados cuando en realidad aquí debería
poner 60 60 60 100 grados porque los
grados están por fuera pero bueno
combinando las dos informaciones los
tres ángulos son de 60 y por lo tanto
tenemos que el triángulo equilátero vale
entonces la respuesta es c y eso quiere
decir que cada una de estas por separado
no nos permite concluir que el triángulo
equilátero pero combinando las dos si
bueno vamos a dejarle hasta aquí le
seguimos en el próximo vídeo